it's just mental tomorrow going to do
something you've been wanting to do hope
that you're desperately scared about
what your parents the world the market
your social media followers will think
do it and then see how not scaring all
the negativity actually is there aren't
right answers tomorrow do the thing that
you've been scared to do that is the
most practical not move across the
country something practical start a
YouTube page tweet about something like
something something you have to
understand there's just decisions
there's no right or wrong because you
don't let me tell you wise when you make
a decision you don't Joe what happened
at the other decision do one thing that
makes you uncomfortable see the reaction
from the audience and your inner family
and your friends and realize very
quickly that it wasn't as scary as you
thought that feedback to go from here to
here because I'm not even asking you to
go for to here you've got understand
there's no right answers they're just
doing he the revenue what legacy I can't
be a bum no I can't be a bum what it has
I'm an idea something just caught my
attention in the mean video can you have
somebody design one that starts the the
top left is a three-time two times
bigger version of my Instagram logo I
think it might stop people even more the
calm before the storm
yeah speaking of New Orleans to a pretty
awesome crew of contractors insurance
policy
executives and so just wear a rock
[Applause]
how are you so he's good to see bro I
love it when dude let's let's let's stay
in the theme of crush and crushing it
let's go into a little bit deeper
because maybe maybe you'll inspire more
than I will how did that first start
like give me give me the details behind
me where were you at and what happened
next
[Music]
[Music]
so just fast forward at Bondi four years
March 6 2017 in a Facebook group CPA
accountant person in a Facebook group
somebody needed help writing a copy you
know it so I went into the group and
help them rewrite their
yep guys self-awareness you don't have
to be great at everything you have to be
great at figuring out what you're great
at and then surrounding yourself with
everything else humility you've got your
ego caught up in this narrative it's the
same thing about high qualities me for a
second while I've got you guys hiring so
many of you have not fired somebody that
you desperately need to fire because
you're the one that hired them and you
have more pride in being good at hiring
than running a good business this is the
psychology that matters
[Music]
yes I get it just mine I get it you you
don't what you do is what I do which is
you're gonna go on a journey of spending
a [ __ ] decade exhaustively standing
up here yelling and screaming and
ranting or calmly or whatever you do you
all you can do is put out the truth and
let the chips fall
you heard me very carefully to my great
ambition here is that two of you
listened and do that is some [ __ ]
numbers there's hundreds and hundreds of
people here but that's what I've learned
which is like I don't you can't what you
can do is a spider humbly and
authentically to get them there and then
just let your skill and and talent and
work ethic create the legacy of how many
people you were able to get there right
look look how I'm thinking about it from
my tree it's like a coaching tree from
my tree to you to you to them and so for
me there's an enormous amount of pride
and how many people I've been able to
hit but some of them maybe in your
breakout session I'm here and you're
here some of the people here didn't get
hit by what I said but maybe in your
breakout session do and honestly that
feels incredible for me because I know
where that seed started
thank you so much thanks New Orleans
no she's gonna start soon mom better to
start working on our signature
negativity can negativity can be leading
at halftime but it's positivity always
wins championships
what's up 3 & 4 you just changed me
Thank You Barry I'll be one of your two
thank you brother make sense right yeah
well I'm a writer I'm an ex director
imax movie producer I'm not doing
anything that's [ __ ] crazy like the
fact that you have an important probably
like it I love it I mean that's yeah to
me that is like trying to give more to
the other person that I wanted in return
every em interaction but everyday before
coffee
you know nothing not for me but man so
I'm doing it every second of my life I'm
trying to give you a better answer they
give you an answer give more back than
you got 5149 biggest changes had like
[Music]
there's no strength there's three things
but there's moments where there's spikes
and when there's spikes
it's like real estate there's Landgraf
there's a land grab in podcasting right
now 100% 100%
we're on Facebook
LinkedIn is like in the words and so's
Twitter but it's but it's also not just
wide which I believe but it's deep yeah
like you could be on Facebook you could
be a contractor you could be a real
estate agent you could be a basketball
player but are you winning so it's you
got to make sure you get your depth down
along with your whip too many people
think like oh we're gonna add podcasting
we're gonna have this but like the thing
that I think I'm doing well is its wide
and deep but that's why there's 17
[ __ ] people and I'm not even happy
you know I think people don't realize to
be great you need both you need to be
wide and deep you just saw the highlight
that's why the rock is pushing me to
expand a lot of you think the answer is
well I'll start a podcast this year or
I'll start a blog too or I'll do I'll do
YouTube videos too with my Facebook or
vice-versa
a lot of you are like oh now I'm gonna
do Facebook Facebook watch along with my
YouTube the problem is 99% of you
haven't gotten the thing you're doing
down right so it's that's the key to me
I think a lot of people are confused by
what's working for me you know I'm not
always just obsessed with doing
everything I'm obsessed with doing
everything right and deep in getting the
value out of it but also not being
crippled for example we had Facebook
down a year and a half ago I don't feel
like we have it down I think we've
nailed it in a little bit in a podcast
kind of Instagram world back on my team
so now I'm like oh [ __ ] over here I've
got to go deeper so it's not only about
going wide or deep in a moment it's
about going wide and deep at all times
that understanding you're pulling those
levers so you're just always getting
your game better it's like being a
professional athlete like you know even
the best the LeBrons the staffs the
Kobe's they talk about like refining
their game in season 12 about a Hall of
Fame career
I'm in a Hall of Fame career I'm trying
to get better at every nuance deeper
wider always and and to many of you are
confused at just adding something Widing
it out is the solve is the unlock
there's no [ __ ] solve or unlock
there's just the [ __ ] past
yeah that last clip of that kid that's
gonna really help a lot of people that's
a real clip worried about your craft not
the algorithm that is that's the mean
but now I don't even now I'm so happy
for you not for anybody else back homes
that makes me I no time to post there's
no hashtag there's no certain content
there's no certain people that follow
you there is no hack what there is is
consistency of like putting out great
content self-aware self-awareness and
and and perseverance and delusion
you know perseverance and delusion look
like
tonight you'll be successful in pretty
much anything you do because you have
the tools to be successful you
understand the patterns they like you'll
be successful if you texted me tomorrow
be like dude sold the house the tree
house you know starting a lemonade
business direct-to-consumer and Amazon
I'm like that's gonna be a successful
lemonade business but that's the same
way that like you know LeBron would be
successful if he wanted to be a football
player now he might not be NFL but it's
just a [ __ ] beast acne I think
there's a lot of people right now that
want to be an entrepreneur because it's
like a rock star status stuff right now
but they can't and so for me
self-awareness like I don't want people
to just not give up because it's what
there's a lot of people who have been
trying to build a business for 11 years
and it's never gonna happen but they
could be an amazing number 3 they should
be my number 3 so subtly honest delusion
of complaining is my biggest one literal
90% of my conversation is predicated on
if you're unhappy the strategy that does
not work is going to other people's
social media and slowing them because
you're happy with yourself or going to
the bar at 4:30 is ringing three Bud
Lights and complaining to the bartender
that's not the strategy tomorrow go and
use something you've been
to do that you're desperately scared
about what your parents in the world the
market your social media followers will
think do it and then see how not scary
all the negativity actually is you have
to understand there's just decisions
there's no right or wrong because you
don't let me tell you why when you make
a decision you don't know what happened
at the other decision do one thing that
makes you uncomfortable see the reaction
from the audience and your inner family
and your friends and realize very
quickly that it wasn't as scary as you
thought that feedback
[Music]
[Music]